how's gun rest my name welcome back to
happy wheels getting back is just baby
baby baby baby Harley's adventure -
that's like a must to play sounds makes
the morning do not play this level if
you are inexperienced with poor
have a point my but no I have to take a
[ __ ] pretty [ __ ] bad at you oh my god
Charlie's never mind they're only
mirages you know it's bad when you have
to take a [ __ ] and you start imagining
toilets all right what do we got here
Sterling College 50 bucks
ah [ __ ] early 59 Cal ham or kisses boss
I don't even know it's the same the best
story of a happy wheels toilet thing
ever all right [ __ ] toilet
happened to be broken
oh you know what [ __ ] it I'm just
kidding all right here we go I'm gonna
dog from my way out of it so that
Buddhists why don't I just let them
produce oh wait what if you have your
pogo stick cut every lining but I okay
if you have a pogo stick you can jump
before them I have to take a [ __ ]
finally ha ha ha
oh that was beautiful how do I fill that
so sorry man
oh no they did touch here oh I'm so
sorry I'm so oh there it is I'm so glass
oh yeah oh yeah take it take it
that was [ __ ] amazing
oh man never change happy wheels never
change
don't move Kelly that's why I love that
[ __ ] oh yeah well we hug we're brother
and sister and with scissor
whoa Andy [ __ ] whoa let's go fast
go fast let it kick edge ah right five
four little by version I don't know
what's wrong with happy wheels developer
I'm not a grammar nazi or anything but
your spelling is worst piece of Mario
Kart kills them that sounds fun what the
hell
why am i Wow let's go whoa
front flap whoa this [ __ ] I won't foot
mated at leas alright let's go yeah ah
[ __ ]
I stole this but no thanks
no no don't leave with iodine I have
again here we go I'm so comfortable
right now every night in my dream why
don't keep singing [ __ ] silly me up I
got y'all right now haha that was nut ah
[ __ ] wow so close man come on [ __ ]
focus man
let's start it out of control here we go
skirt a [ __ ] fast but that's okay all
right
oh that bake I made it
that's the flesh wound don't worry about
it's totally worth it ah speed I tried
once
it was fun I went fast I was getting
high the rules are drive slowly don't
kill people and don't have fun
what whoa what what are you doing
bye you're just kidding do what you want
by by the [ __ ] okay might be my
character okay I just want to get
badness yes you like this [ __ ] boy I'm
looking at yo you're like well Santa
what I kiss you bye I guess it a try oh
yes Gus I'm gone
you can do it what what it's Santa doing
to that lady that was she doing okay I
got it Clem just ah goddamn it you
didn't go fast enough this map is called
a speed what the [ __ ] all right all
right sign here we go but don't you
watch the med school and uh yeah school
is for Santa class and we're what the
hell is that guy ah here we go
my god look everyone Oh
backflip opinions know we're still alive
[ __ ] still alive surfing black people
there big [ __ ] oh yeah
all right purple ball of death whoa best
start
okay okay okay hey we got rowdy ice [ __ ]
we're not even attached to each other
whoa Ronnie like a true dog oh [ __ ] yeah
[ __ ] yeah best map ever okay let's take
another joke and I click the same one
I'm a [ __ ] [ __ ] all right here we go
all right here we go
yeah yeah yeah I don't need sausages
[ __ ] every time I see a lady would be
one of these in real life I always think
of happy wheels it's like happy wheels
infected what the hell is going out with
my bike watch it whoa oh man her titties
got pierced oh this looks nice hey best
back we're on a date in this beautiful
valley and love it look a beautiful belt
yes it is pretty beautiful Crystal River
I've nan eyes he's humping his son while
they're fishing
that's lovely playground ah that's a
sweet what is this diamond waterfall oh
that's beautiful yeah military training
I don't want to go there
right no oh thank god thank heavens
oh no what is this keep out why am i got
wait a second I lose my foot I haven't
no tit
oh no go this looks scary then go that I
don't know how to trust that's bad man
that's for this job eh yeah I got you
now you son of a [ __ ]
save me a Vespa on no we go what the
hell I don't want to kiss him I don't
want to do it you would kiss his legs
for the eternity that's know I'll see in
a second again oh I don't know how I
made a habit
oh that hurt man go slow all right cool
I'll listen
try the taunted tour to the room I come
on Dell Wyse my time woman yeah
where's y'all buy that it's cool you can
take different paths and that but I
don't know yeah yeah they see me jumping
they hump thing they think I'm pretty
[ __ ] cool and [ __ ] so I go down here
Teddy catch me ridin dirty tryna catch
me ridin Ruby just get me bad and ER no
don't try to make everybody ready to be
anybody oh now that's dead people it
tells me I should go there but I will go
to town I come on make it brief break
tear Darwin's just mom let me go get her
away from you all right mom don't scare
little [ __ ] boy all right
whoa let's dance baby yeah yeah [ __ ]
love dancing with the television or
television why haven't I seen you before
you're so beautiful come here come here
[ __ ] yeah oh god what's happening whoa I
can do some epic dancing oh my god
gosh and you must go without me what the
hell okay
no van Petey armies that was I
with special guests you broke their
wheels good back in hey that's more like
an you get hey get that
whoa Adele let's go why don't you do a
backflip but dunk
hey this is the kind of curl it's like a
combination PewDiePie uh-oh its I only
should I go this way maybe dad and I'm
Cat Cat whoa oh I needed the speed
that's fine
backflip down Chad why but I love your
foot we're finally together finally I
don't okay don't
ah you still have that annoying voice
come on let me ah [ __ ] I'm stuck no
that's that pain in the ass it's not as
bad as ah nah goddamn it alright let's
go my back it's no way I kept how it's
nothing do that
come on man come on you're better than
this did it it it it it it it him bumps
oh yeah speed speed speed
mmm yes my [ __ ] I got you I saw snap
Oh be quick whoa why in my pot all right
there we go no be careful bad
[ __ ] you Berra oh whoa - yeah alright
[ __ ] the world sorry that's my leg my
leg I don't want it look at that [ __ ] I
can't read it
[ __ ] oh he got me iced let take me it
took me back back
where's good nice guy
like a wrecking ball no I have an idea
share what Acme poop rooster back all
right let's see yeah melon Allah all the
pieces finish the race like a bus
why can't you appreciate more than one
year to a lack of us anyway
I will actually under here bros like
babies in you alright just kind of come
bread today and I'll see you next
episode of whatever I make stay awesome
rest
don't think I'd see you in yeah
you drink it sneak it snooker